yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
as I said in my review the secret life
of pets is basically Toy Story for
animals with Dukas Buzz Lightyear and
Max's woody but there are also some
pretty cool references to other movies
as well as illuminations own minions and
Despicable Me films so in this video I'm
going to look at some of the best Easter
eggs the filmmakers snuck into the film
and if you spotted any others I'd love
to hear about them in the comments below
there will of course be a few spoilers
ahead so you want to avoid those you can
click or tap up here in the top right of
the screen for my spoiler free review of
the movie minions is illuminations most
successful movie to date so as well as
making the fun short film mower minions
which plays before the main movie the
studio's animators also included a good
number of minions Easter eggs and the
secret life of pets itself there's a
minions toy which you can see on this
boy's bedside table as well as another
one that's out of shot and there's a
minions magnet on the fridge in Katie's
apartment and further down the fridge is
a postcard featuring the minions
favorite food a banana plus during the
mid-credits scene the perk mel was a
minions fancy dress outfit to a party at
the apartment to the head-banging poodle
Leonard in the scene where Duke drags
max around by the lead the song happy
can be heard playing in a taxi cab in
the background happy was one of the
numerous songs at Pharrell Williams
composed and performed for the
soundtrack of Despicable Me 2 and was
nominated for Best Original Song at the
Oscars the names Arella which was the
Italian restaurant where GRU went on a
disastrous date in Despicable Me 2
appears on the streets of New York
though this time it's ireli shoes
there's a poster for illuminations next
animated feature sing on the back of the
bus that snowball dries when he's
chasing after the animal control truck
singer's a musical comedy set in a world
entirely inhabited by animals and stars
Matthew McConaughey Reese Witherspoon
Seth MacFarlane and Scarlett Johansson
among many others and during that scene
the way the flushed pets gang swarm onto
the bridge and slide down its cables
readying themselves for tak Max the dog
has echoes of the scene towards the end
of Rise of the Planet of the Apes where
the Apes overrun the Golden Gate Bridge
and the killer instincts of the crazy
bunny snowball and the way he attacks
the animal control officer are a nice
nod to the killer rabbit of caerbannog
for Monty Python and the Holy Grail and
his demented laughter also reminded me
of the evil bunny boy and go from
hoodwinked there's a visual shout out to
Alfred Hitchcock's classic horror film
the birds via a framed poster you can
glimpse a suitably enough in the home of
the budgerigar sweet pea there's a
lovely little emerge to the end of
director Billy Wilder's classic romantic
comedy some like is hot when the old
basset hound pops ask Chloe where she's
from and she replies dude I'm a cat to
which pop says well nobody's perfect
that's actually the closing line from
some like it's hot which jerry brown's
character says to Jack Lemmon after
lemon who's disguised as a woman reveals
that you can't marry Brown as he's
actually a man and there's a cool
reference to Marilyn Monroe who also
starred in some like it hot in the
painting of Gidget in her apartment that
inspired by Andy Warhol's famous Marilyn
diptych there's an alaria strip on the
movie Grease in the sausage factory
scene where we see a fantasy sequence of
sausages singing and dancing to the hit
musicals closing song we go together on
top of that the choreography and
geometric shapes in the sausage song and
dance scene also pay homage to the
musical numbers staged by famed director
and musical choreographer Busby Berkeley
whose movies include 42nd Street and
babes in arms director Chris Renaud
cameos in the movie as a voice of the
guinea pig Norman who spends the movie
trying to find his way back home through
the ventilation shaft in Max's apartment
block
Rene's daughter Keeley also cameos as
the voice of Molly and Jane the virgin
store Jaime Camil plays Fernanda the
star of gidget's favorite telenovela la
pasión de la pasión so guys did you spot
any other interesting Easter eggs in the
secret life of pets and what did you
think of the movie let me know in the
comments below and if you enjoyed this
do like share and subscribe and also
check out my Easter egg playlist or you
might like to check out some of my
amazing deleted scenes from the animated
movies finding Dory and Zootopia in my
deleted scenes playlist thanks for
watching and see you next time you be
guy a movie lovers
you